bonsoir alexandre del valle merci d'être
avec nous les relations entre la france
et la turquie est ce qu'elles ont déjà
été aussi mauvaise par le passé non je
pense que l on était déjà mauvaise dans
le passé dans les années 2000 de
l'affairé shalaan par rapport aux urnes
cetera mais est aussi la reconnaissance
du génocide arménien mais ça n'a jamais
été aussi violent quand je parle de
violence et pas eu de guerre bien sûr
mais dans les mots on n'a jamais été
aussi loin en violences ce qu'a dit
monsieur erdogan contre le président
macro est assez stupéfiant entre pays
soi disant amis alliés membres de la
même organisation l'otan c'est
extrêmement violent la campagne anti
française lancée par les frères
musulmans le pakistan le qatar et la
turquie contre la france a été
absolument inouïe ça a même dépassé la
violence des propos turcot officielle
contre l'autriche ou l'allemagne ou la
belgique il ya quelques années lorsque
ces pays avait interdit dès des meetings
turc en faveur du référendum qui a donné
les pleins pouvoirs erdogan
non non c'est quelque chose d'inouï par
la violence des mots alors sous sarkozy
il ya eu aussi des choses équivalente
rappelez vous quand comme un suaire de
galles en voulait à sarkozy pour la
seconde loi sur le génocide arménien des
propos avaient été assez outrancier
accusant le père de sarkozy d'avoir
participé à la légion étrangère au
génocide de plusieurs millions
d'algériens
erdogan avait juste oublié que le père
de sarkozy n'avait pas participé la
guerre d'algérie donc y est habitué à
des propos transfert de garde mais là on
a senti une faiblesse il a cru que macro
ont été faibles qu'il pouvait lui taper
dessus de salé l'effrayer ça a provoqué
l'effet contraire puisque aujourd'hui
comme vous savez une chypre et la grèce
remercie la france du courage de macron
qui a quand même montré les muscles qui
a envoyé des frégates qui des
dispositifs militaires sous marin de
passer par là pour bloquer la turquie
qui voulait que pratiquement un excès
les eaux territoriales chypriote et
grecque il ya quelques mois la rixe
de macron a surpris erdogan qui croyait
qu'il avait à faire un espèce de
bisounours
alain trudeau auto gentil et incapables
de réaction et il est extrêmement
surpris yoga c'est seulement ce sont en
gros des rapports de force à rapport de
force entre deux hommes forts lequel a
le plus de chances de l'emporter
alors bien entendu je pense qu erdogan a
le plus de chances de l'emporter à moyen
et à long terme parce que erdogan a
derrière lui un peuple extrêmement
nationaliste il a muselé tous les médias
il est capable aujourd'hui d'imposer sa
volonté il a il a vu que la force ça
marche
les rapports de force il entend
d'ailleurs assez bien avec poutine
puisque les deux se sont rendu compte
qu'ils ont affaire à quelqu'un de très
têtu et de muscler et les deux
finalement s'entend sur le partage de la
syrie il dit souvent nous nous entendons
sur nos discorde et il s'entend sur le
fait qu'ils sont pas d'accord et du coup
ils ce sont des partages à l'instar de
mathieu qui se partagent d'aider des
territoires et erdogan sait que le
système démocratique lui-même ne
permettrait pas à macro de faire des
négociations à la poutine où on se
partage fluence comme au 19e siècle
il sait que structurellement les
démocraties ne peuvent pas fonctionner
comme des pays un peu plus viril ou
autoritaires ou voir des pays et
dictature des dictatoriaux donc il
compte là dessus il sait très bien que
si macron par exemple vous voulez jouer
à des rapports de force au sein même de
sa majorité
il y aurait des tendances dont on parle
aujourd'hui c'est ça la mode depuis
quelques jours les islamo gauchiste il y
en a même dans la dans la majorité de
mâcon dont erdogan joue sur les
divisions d'ailleurs erdogan comme
futile mais aussi comme d'autres hommes
forts du monde multipolaire se disent
les démocraties sont structurellement
faible parce que le le système des
démocraties avec les divergences
d'opinion l'instabilité les alternances
permanente permettent de faire en sorte
que on a des arnauds des interlocuteurs
fragile et qui ne reste pas longtemps au
pouvoir tandis que nous nous avons une
véritable politique de longue durée avec
des pouvoirs autoritaires qui peuvent
sans racines et alors nos confères de
journal du dimanche avance que des
associations financées par l'état
turquie essaie de d'accroître en
influence de la turquie dans la société
française notamment sur la scène des
politiques locales et la religion est ce
que ces allégations vous semble crédible
aujourd'hui ce que l'on sait c'est que
il y a deux grandes pôles qui essaie
d'instrumentaliser islam de france et d'
instrumentaliser la religion en saveurs
d'agenda impérialistes irrédentistes
islamistes c'est premièrement les frères
musulmans structure arabophone mais
mondial aujourd'hui également de ses
dents talent et ceux qui travaillent et
rate étroitement avec les frères
musulmans
et bien c'est les réseaux islamistes
turcs qui jadis était séparé du
politique à l'époque du kémalisme et qui
depuis hier d'organes sont repris en
main par l'islam d'état qui je répète
pendant longtemps l'islam d'état turque
et était contre l'islamisme turc y avait
une énorme confrontation entre les deux
erdogan a réuni les instruments fille
ciel des réseaux des mosquées et des
associations islamistes turcs en europe
1 qui aujourd'hui sont repris en main
par le diamètre le ministère turc eu
d'erreur région et consulaires qui gère
les mosquées en france les fameux ditib
sans parler d'autres associations
islamistes assez radicales comme les
milli gorus le milieu lui c'est
l'association originel de l'islam
politique turque d'ailleurs dont vient
monsieur erdogan et son mentor erbakan
donc il ya aujourd'hui une véritable
instrumentalisation du religieux pour
faire de l'ingérence politique
pourquoi il faut se mettre à la place
des arts de gamme c'est malin s'ils
décident et turcs ne s'intègrent pas
qu'il serait islamisme et et qu'ils
adhèrent à l'islam en nationalisme
d'erdogan
ils vont moins s'intégrer ils vont
garder la nationalité turque et ils vont
voter c'est une réserve des lecteurs
énorme
erdogan sait que si un électeur turc né
en france et son fils s'intègrent et
deviennent laïque et bien qu'ils ne
voteront pas pour rire de gains par
contre si grâce à la parano là parce que
j'appelle la stratégie de par
anodisation en faisant croire que les
français persécutent les turcs et
musulmans
si on arrive à resserrer les liens des
communautés dans un
une logique séparatiste comme justement
dit macron et bien ces gens vont rester
en quelque sorte endogame vont par
s'intégrer et ils vont continuer à être
une réserve des lecteurs pourrir dogan
il faut savoir qu'il ya 4 millions il ya
une réserve des lecteurs pour erdogan de
4 millions en dehors de la turquie dont
3 ou 4 millions entre la france la
belgique les moeurs de l'europe et
l'allemagne
c'est une c ça peut faire la différence
dans une élection donc c'était plutôt
électoraliste dans cette attitude
agressive de d'erdogan
si à l'avenir les relations le
s'arranger parce que vous les avez
décrite très mauvaises entre la france
et la turquie est ce que ça pourrait
remettre en cause selon vous le
fonctionnement de l'otan je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il a aussi su erdogan a
été choqué il a fait celui qui était
choqué lorsque macro ont dit que le
temps était en mort cérébrale
mais on le sait depuis la première mêmes
dates et surtout la deuxième bien idole
en irak dont c'est à dire depuis le
milieu des années le début des années
2000 déjà george bush le père est
ensuite fils avaient été choqués du
manque de solidarité de la turquie lors
des guerres en irak pour une raison
logique d'ailleurs un tout pour les
turcs on a déstabilisé le moyen-orient
et on a réveillé le séparatisme kurde en
irak est aujourd'hui maintenant syrie et
donc indirectement aussi en turquie
donc il y a une une perception mutuelle
négative extrêmement forte entre les
deux pays
en gros pour la turquie l'otan
déstabilise la turquie en réveillant et
l'irrédentisme kurdes au moyen-orient et
de l'autre côté pour l'europe la turquie
est un prédateur un état impérialiste
qui étend des réseaux néo ottoman pour
conquérir à la fois des pays arabes sont
des plaies d'ailleurs beaucoup aux
égyptiens aux émirats et pour s'emparer
du gaz en méditerranée orientale qui est
aussi une pierre d'achoppement avec nous
puisqu'on a des intérêts pétroliers
aussi en méditerranée orientale comme
aussi les grecs mais si brillante mais
aussi les italiens avec lenny nous
voyons on a plein de dossiers
d'affrontements à la fois religieux
politiques historiques gazier
énergétique et bien sûr le contrôle de
la libye
1ce ce que va devenir la libye dans le
futur la nature qui essaient de profiter
de la guerre civile ni viennent pour
s'emparer aussi
du pétrole onshore en libye en plus de
gaz offshore en méditerranée et et
partout dans ces pourrait rajouter aussi
le haut karabakh de la france et la
turquie sont en désaccord total sur tout
mais aussi la france et l'otan depuis au
moins 20 ans l'otan voit la turquie
comme un véritable cauchemar parce qu'on
ne sait pas comment expulser et la
turquie possède 50 missiles nucléaires
américains sur son sol
comment faire à un pays qui est la plus
grande armée de l'otan terrestre le plus
grand nombre de soldats mais qui abrite
aussi du matériel nucléaire de l'otan et
des américains c'est pas un pays dont on
peut se débarrasser comme ça ou vous
expulse de l'otan pratiquement tous les
membres de l'otan aimerait que la
turquie n'en fasse plus partie mais on
ne sait pas comment revenir en arrière
on a donné à la turquie un pouvoir de
nuisance gigantesque au dans le cadre
des armements de l'otan qu'elle abrite
sur son sol et qu'elle pourrait ne pas
rendre si facilement qu'on le voudrait
merci beaucoup alexandre del valle
géopolitologue écrivain pour cette
analyse merci à vous